you you would offer me cheap
juice is that it the pm and chance of
visiting an energy company in london
we're plugging green electricity but
this government's actually trying to
plug holes in test and trace
after nearly 16 000 positive tests
were not recorded in the last week of
september because of a technical glitch
some of the data it got truncated and
and it was lost but what they've
done now is uh not only contacted all
the people
who were identified as having the
disease i mean that that was done
uh in the first place but they're now
working through all the contacts as well
officials now scrambling to contact tens
of thousands of potentially infectious
people
who've been going about their lives as
normal a significant
failure at a crucial time the health
secretary playing down the significance
our assessment of the disease and its
impact
has not substantially changed as a
result of these data
and the jbc has confirmed that this has
not
impacted the basis on which decisions
about local action were taken
last week nevertheless this is a serious
issue which is being investigated
fully the error may not have affected
the rules but delayed contact racing may
have affected the spread
that means as many as 48 000
contacts not traced and not isolating
thousands of people blissfully unaware
they've been exposed to covid
potentially spreading this deadly virus
this isn't just a shambles
it's so much worse than that than this
and it gives me no comfort to say it
but it's putting lives at risk public
trust damage
too this is another incident which
further undermines public confidence in
the delivery of the government's covered
response
it was two weeks ago that the prime
minister stood in the commons and told
us we faced a perilous turning point
in this pandemic that's when he ordered
closing time to move to 10 p.m
told us all to work from home again if
we can driving down
case numbers as a collective endeavor it
requires us to comply
and the government to be competent and
this latest
error risks undermining that public
confidence in the government
at a critical time in manchester cases
are spreading faster
than anywhere else in the country it's
very confusing because they change the
policy every
like every other day we're informed the
count is going up
whether it's by a thousand for me or ten
thousand not as
important as making sure that the rules
are clear
i don't think anybody knows where
they're coming or going it's no wonder
if people are confused
you know on the rules of regulations i
don't know where i am
greater manchester has been in local
lockdown since the end of july and
people
are losing faith trying to follow the
rules but with no
results a recipe for a winter of
discontent
beth rigby sky news westminster